go get her kiss her
that's kim kardashian who has finally
become obsessed
with this year's ben sensation bridgeton
and her reactions
are priceless it's a different
experience for sure on sunday the
reality star shared these moments to her
instagram stories
yes along with good friends stephanie
shepherd and tracy romulus
she went on an emotional journey look at
you you're downright flush
yes this is what happens when one is
angry when one burns for someone who
does not feel the same
in particular the romance story line
between simon
and daphne played by reggae gene page
and phoebe denver
it doesn't get more dramatic or dishier
it's a full-on
dinner plate lunch plate and breakfast a
dish nothing but dish
kim shared her many emotional reactions
including these images where she wrote
what is happening i'm not crying and i'm
not
okay and we heard these wishful whispers
as the drama heated up
yes
go get her kiss her
and when simon and daphne finally locked
lips
kim and her gal pals were literally
squealing
but you need not harm any doubts of my
intention to support your sister
her well-being is my responsibility now
i'm gonna take that duty with the utmost
seriousness
at the same time kim was fan girling
over bridgeton sunday night
this one uh as i think kind of
spilled out my brain in the moments
after it's announced
gregor gene page was accepting an naacp
image award
for outstanding actor in a drama series
reggae john page bridges
nah um these
are wow it is the highest honor to
represent us in the fullness of our
humanity of our beauty of our joy of our
glamour of our splendor
of our royalty of our romance of our
love it is the highest honor to
represent that
and to represent the people i do
represent and i will do my absolute best
to be worthy of that
while speaking with press after the
ceremony reggae jean said he is very
aware of how obsessed people have become
with the series
the last few months have been uh
wonderful on a number of levels in terms
of um
gaining a wider audience but in seeing
how many people the show's connected
with and seeing how viscerally it's
connected with them and seeing
what uh an emotional connection people
have formed with the work
we put out which is everything you ever
want as an artist is everything you kind
of dream of achieving
and hope to achieve every time it's
wonderful to see it come to life
so it's been great